[Music]  hi checking in its what's 45th birthday  soiree years this place has its own  magic I think you're gonna let smell  nice this is such a great spread on a  wiener watch fingers honey good it's  nice to get away and unplug this place  is just so relax I'm trying to get our  buns in gear for Earth waffle hut so is  that a plan my caddy today we have birds  of prey watching it's nice to get a  break from the group right honestly I  just need a drink  we're doing whatever the f we want  [Music]  Catherine why is your face so tight did  you put on a night cream bundiada  bundiada bundiada bundiada is her  diagnosis and she's mentally quite sound  great thing about life you can feel fine  but also know that you're a ticking time  bomb why do you have to be so  controlling about everything take take  take I just want to say I'm now ready to  forgive all of you bundiada boom  [Music]  you